your first your last name spot after me  okay girl lucas  g-e-a-r-l-d l-u-c-a-s  i'm from gary indiana perfect tell us  what you're feeling right now  uh well at the moment i'm actually  kind of happy that there  came out with a verdict not because i am  black because  it's for people of america  and we are in a tough time right now  just just  happy that we uh got a  perfect birdie not a perfect verdict  uh uh good verdict guilty guilty are you  hoping this is the start of some change  yeah we're long way from change but  i hope that it does something that  gets us toys that way you know  no just thanks yo thank y'all for  being just coming up on us even giving  us that news  because we're here on vacation and we  wouldn't even know that  until we got home